it was a defining image of the war so
far
that moment last wednesday which
captured such cruelty
but if there had been some hope then a
sign that she and her baby would be okay
well it wasn't to be okay
while we were resuscitating her and
treating her for shock we carried out a
caesarean section and took out her
lifeless child more than 30 minutes of
resuscitation didn't produce any results
then more than 30 minutes of
resuscitation of the mother didn't
produce any results
both died
in the same city over the past 24 hours
more terror
more civilians targeted an apartment
block hit
then the sound of another plane
the only place for cover
is the place they just escaped
mario paul is a city surrounded
cut off bombarded
the cruelty the tragedy is
unquestionable but the crime must be
proven
bill wiley is executive director of the
commission for international justice and
accountability his teams gather the
evidence to present to court
and what we all see here is not enough
it's definitely not enough what we look
for in cases such as these were where
you're looking at shelling rocketing
aerial attacks and so forth is we tend
not to focus on a specific incident
we're looking at patterns the key
is
somewhat paradoxically it's it's not
safe footage
uh from the crime scenes we're actually
looking for material generated by the
attacking force
there is a pattern now and it stretches
across the country in kharkiv ukraine's
second city freedom square a regional
administration building and surrounding
residential areas hit at the start of
the month
[Music]
in the same city possible use of cluster
munitions
not a direct war crime but surely
indiscriminate bombing
and in the last 24 hours here at least
two people killed in their homes
urpin northwest of kiev will be a key
focus for investigators here's just one
incident last week
a huge explosion as civilians tried to
flee
tatiana parabenas and her two children
elise and nikita were killed instantly
and back in mario paul we believe this
was in the last 24 hours a school
this is school number 36. elementary
school was here
there were no military at this school
russia of course denies targeting
civilians and instead it points the
finger back at the ukrainians
mariopol's main hospital has not been
hit and inside in the intensive care
unit
in the fight to treat the survivors of
all this
the cry this time
is of life
her name is alana mark stone sky news